grant chaps transport secretary is with
us not a very rosy picture is it mr
schatz
it isn't and very unnecessary as well
when it comes to these um strikes i uh
you know
i hear the unions say that it's about
pay i hear they say it's about job cuts
in fact there's a payoff on the table
and the job cuts are by and large
voluntary um so it's unnecessary it's
taking us
back to the bad old days of of uh of
union strikes and uh you know they've
walked away now from the negotiations
yesterday saying that they were going to
strike and calling off any chance of a
resolution
what are you going to do about it
well we're going to have to push on with
these reforms anyway that the railways
run in many ways based on rules which
were put in place in for example the
1950s and haven't much moved on so
they're not run in the interests of
passengers they're all sorts of very
very restrictive practices which carry
on and for example
time sheets with network rail have to be
filled out in many cases manually rather
than on computers and you know that kind
of modernization the types of things
which prevent uh modernization in in the
way that the railways uh up kept the
upkeep of the railways those things have
to change and we're going to push on
with that in any case and i see that
network rail
have written to the unions last night to
say that since they've come to the end
of the road and the unions have gone on
strike some of these changes will now
need to be
implemented
yeah my point is what are you going to
do about the strike
well the strikes this week are
a reality they they've they've called
these three days of of strikes
what we'll do in future though is make
sure that we've uh put some additional
protections in place for the traveling
public for example through uh minimum
service levels which is something that
we included in our manifesto that would
mean that on a day like today a certain
level of service would still have to be
uh
run
and through changes to allow for
transferable workers that's a much
quicker change that we can make and that
means that somebody who works for
example for the railway companies at the
moment or for network rail
could switch uh to uh for example uh
carry out another role for which they're
fully qualified and trained and provide
more flexibility on our railways so
there are there are things that we're
going to do
uh to push ahead even though we don't
seem to have the cooperation of the
unions at the moment but as ever we want
the unions to uh come and resolve these
these these talks have been going on for
a long time and there's simply no reason
to come back today
okay come back to that in a sec we need
to be information rich because people
want to know what's going on so are you
saying that you are changing the law and
you're also bringing in agency workers
so this won't be a problem later on in
the week not quite no that's not right
um nothing that we can do
this week would change the reality for
the strikes this week law changes take
time
we've always hoped not to have to change
the law because we've been talking to
the unions for a long time
over a package of reforms about 20
different areas of reform with network
rail uh and there's always hope we
wouldn't need to get to this point but
for future strikes uh both in the uh in
in this current uh strike but also uh
for other strikes uh we're going to
ensure that the the law is firmly on the
passenger side on the consumer side when
it's not a rail strike
well one of the ways is through that
transferable skills or agency workers as
you as you call it another is through
providing minimum service levels and
there are a number of other technical
changes that we can make
to union laws to make sure that the
public is always protected i don't think
it's acceptable that people who've
perhaps waited for two years to get a
hospital appointment today may not be
able to get to it the kids who are doing
their gcses and a levels this week 17
public exams they won't be able to get
to in some cases it's not acceptable to
disrupt businesses that are just getting
back on their feet and so we are going
to take steps to make sure that this
type of thing
is
you know less damaging in the future for
people
okay but how
how are you going to do that minister
uh well specifically changes through
secondary legislation and through
primary legislation which means passing
laws in parliament
okay what's the law going to say
well the you you mentioned about the uh
agency or transferable uh workers uh
that's a law at the moment that for
example if you have a
somebody who works at a terminal in a uh
operation center at network rail and is
fully qualified to work at the next
terminal at the moment there isn't the
flexibility for that person to be asked
oh actually for this afternoon can you
man this terminal over here
it would provide that kind of
flexibility that you'd have in any other
business this is this is a sort of these
are the sort of working practices that
have developed and been allowed to
continue on our railways uh because
we've got quite militant unions that
we're having to work with calling
strikes on an unnecessary basis telling
their workers uh that there was no pay
rise being offered when in fact the pay
freeze from coronavirus had already come
to an end and thanking people who had
dished out 600 pounds per family 16
billion pounds of taxpayers money by
going on strike the first opportunity
that they've had
okay what why aren't you rolling up your
sleeves and getting around the table
with the unions this week so that we
won't have another two strikes well the
employers are the people to be round the
table with the unions they have done
they've met with them on 60 plus
separate occasions six zero uh separate
occasions it's always the employers and
the unions who have to come to a
settlement in these things they're the
ones with the technical details they're
the ones who uh
who actually have the mandate to do the
settlement as well so uh you know it's
always the case it's the employers and
the unions who get together on these
things
yeah but am i not right in saying that
the government is the only shareholder
in network rail it belongs to the
government the government sets its
funding um
you are involved whether you're saying
you are or not you're the transport
secretary it's your responsibility to
keep the country running why aren't you
rolling up your sleeves and sorting it
out
well if i thought there was even a one
in a million chance that my uh being in
the room would uh help source it out
then i'd be there
network
mick lynch is the uh head of uh
of the union the rmt um said last month
that he would never negotiate in his
words with the tory uh government uh in
fact uh government of course in every
single uh public strikers of course
ultimately uh
uh ultimately um the the the pay the the
pay master behind it but we set a remit
and it's for the employers to uh make
the negotiated um settlement and it
wouldn't help in fact it would actually
undermine the process for ministers to
walk in the room uh looking back at
every strike that i can see in the past
including why
what was he gonna say looking back at
every strike
because these are highly technical
negotiations they involve 20 plus areas
of reform which are required which are
extremely technical and that needs the
employer and the union to decide i'd say
this is a bit of a red herring uh you're
saying it because the unions and labour
have suddenly got together and said why
aren't ministers in the room i should
remind them that when there were
firefighter strikes under blair and the
unions were calling for ministers to be
in in the room uh it remained with the
employers when there were strikes by the
post office workers under brown and
labor uh were asked to be in the room
the ministers were asked to be in the
room the then labour government said
that of course it has to be settled via
the employers and the union so it's
standard it's standard practice yes
indeed but it's standard practice i'm
just pointing out that there is no role
for ministers to directly walk through i
think what you're asking for is for me
to go back to the sort of the bad old
days of the 1970s where the then
labour prime minister harold wilson had
beer and sandwiches with them in in
downing street and it did not work out
well i do not think that that is the way
forward
it's not working out very well today
either is it
yeah are you saying it's no no mister
shops i mr shops are you saying it's too
technical for you to get involved
i'm saying the employers are the people
with the mandate they're the people who
need to settle okay
okay but but you are the transport
secretary you represent the government
in other words ergo you represent the
traveling public
and they for the rest of this week are
going to be basically at a standstill as
you said people could die as a result of
these strikes you need to roll your
sleeves up you need to get in that
meeting room with the unions and you
need to sort this out is what my viewers
will be shouting at their tellies this
morning
well as i've tried to explain to you
several times uh that is not the way
that industrial disputes are resolved
they never have been since the days of
beer and sandwiches at number 10 in the
1970s uh and it didn't work out very
well then the way that
disputes need to be resolved are always
between the employer and the employees
the unions themselves as i said the
unions have called a strike under a
false pretence there was always going to
be a pay offer on the table they took
their members out to strike
telling them that there wouldn't be by
balloting in april before uh the pay
freeze would have been unfrozen uh
nationally we've got a completely
unnecessary very very damaging um strike
they are hurting precisely the people
that they claim to be protecting because
white collar workers who can simply stay
at home use their computers log in by
zooms or teams will carry on as before
the people they're hurting are people
who physically need to turn out up for
work maybe on lower pay perhaps the
cleaners in hospitals and the rest and
it's very damaging of these unions i
absolutely deplore what they're doing
today and there is no excuse for taking
people out on strike under false
presences and that is exactly what that
okay
okay just because you've explained it to
me several times mr shap doesn't mean
that you point is necessarily valid i go
back to the point that the government is
the only shareholder in network rail it
belongs to the government the government
sets its funding how can you claim not
to be involved and not to want to be
involved and and not being able to get
involved when that is at the exact point
you should be speaking to the unions you
should be getting around the table and
you should be sorting out this mess your
country has come to a standstill and
it's your responsibility
i i understand that you want us to go
back to the 70s and beer and sandwiches
with unions and ministers negotiating
all right it's just
it's just not how it works
it's just not how it works
if you if you're saying that every time
there is a dispute uh the what's
required is for ministers to personally
go and negotiate the resolution then why
hasn't that happened when there was a
junior doctor's dispute why didn't it
happen when there was a firefighter's
dispute why didn't it happen
with
other disputes including for example
when the post office
workers went on strike you know as well
as i do the employers are the people
with the mandate the employers are the
ones with the technical details to
negotiate this this is a stunt which i'm
afraid you're falling for by the unions
and the labour party the labour party
who won't even condemn these strikes
today and the unions who only last month
were saying they would not negotiate
with the government and have suddenly
decided uh running out of things to say
that they'll suddenly call on ministers
to talk to them and walk in the room
with them directly it wouldn't resolve
anything in fact it would make matters
worse and that's why i'm not in the room
okay
you keep banging on about the 1970
we look as though we're heading towards
a summer of discontent uh hearing from
the prime minister that he doesn't want
inflation busting pay rises as a result
of that we're hearing that even criminal
barristers are thinking about going on
strike we're hearing that nurses are
thinking about going on strike doctors
are thinking about going on strike care
workers are thinking of going on strike
teachers are thinking of going on strike
who is it that's taking us back to the
1970s
well we're clearly having a a difficult
time along with the rest of the world
with inflation right now uh it's a
global phenomenon after coronavirus
exacerbated by putin's invasion of
ukraine everyone's going through the
same thing i don't think we'll end up
there and i very much hope we won't and
in particular in the area that i know
best on these rail strikes there's no
need for it because there are so many
reforms that are required uh that would
make the railway much more modern and
run in favor of the passenger that in
return for those we can pay a pay
increase and unlike the message from the
unions in this particular dispute uh we
most likely don't need to make
compulsory job cuts for the most part
this will come through voluntary in fact
we've already had more people come
through voluntarily than we could accept
uh to leave the the railways um so uh
you know these these are strikes being
called under false protesters i hope
that in other areas which i'll know
about in less detail we don't get to
strikes as well and i think after the
the whole country i mentioned the 16
billion pounds we put into protecting
the railway it's been the same across
the economy that's 160 000 pounds per
rail employee i don't think it's a way
to thank people for their uh for their
hard-earned cash going into supporting
the railway by then immediately calling
a strike as we try to recover from
coronavirus
just before i let you go just to clarify
you're saying that if you were in the
room with the unions it would make
matters worse is that what you're saying
it's a stunt by the unions who could
settle this today they've had a pay
offer they know that these reforms which
they've been resisting for decades need
to go ahead these work practices that
prevent us from running a railway seven
days a week from treating sundays like
any other working day for example are
long long overdue
railway workers are fortunately well
paid the medium salary is 44 000. the
average salary for a train driver is 59
000 pounds that compares with 31 000 for
a nurse and the government has to make
uh that overall a choice of balancing
pay across the public sector fortunately
railway workers have been well paid it's
at time to get this strike settled and i
do call on the unions to come back to
the negotiating table and fix this thing